I'm a scientist and I'm a big fan of
Star Trek especially of mr. Spock
mr. Spock is the scientist as well and
at the same time he's the first
commander of the Starship Enterprise and
during the adventures of the Enterprise
crew he and his colleagues are dealing a
lot with the presence or absence of mr.
Spock's emotions mr. Spock is half human
and half Vulcan and Vulcans are an alien
race who learned to control and suppress
their feelings and to act purely out of
logic as mr. Spock is only half Vulcan
he sees himself constantly in conflict
in between logic and emotions and as
he's part of a team the whole crew is
struggling with is analyzing and is
making fun of this conflict and also the
fans of Star Trek watch with amusement
the seemingly contradictory behavior
they find and quite fascinating and the
matter is a golden thread through the
whole Star Trek series and movies from
the 60s until today and that's actually
what I want to talk about today the role
of emotions in science we tend to think
that science is all about facts and
logic and human feelings are often
neglected or considered an obstacle to
get rid of I would like to suggest that
emotions are as important in science as
they are in any other part of our lives
science is made by humans and as human
beings even if we try hard we cannot get
rid of our emotions so instead of
fighting them I believe that even in
science we should make use of our
feelings because for breakthroughs and
innovation they are equally important as
facts and logic I will come back to mr.
Spock's but first let me share my
experience on the role of emotions and
science and one story in particular kept
me thinking about it for the last couple
of years
I'm working in research on organic
light-emitting diodes so called
ohlet's this is how you might know them
as a new generation of this place
ohlet's are more and more used in
smartphone displays and TV screens they
make them appear bright truly colorful
and bendable this is how they look like
in the research lab of my physicist
colleagues and this is what I as a
chemist have in mind when I think about
them I've loved it ever since I started
to work on it so I didn't really like
the news when the company I had been
working for that was my previous
employer announced that I wanted to stop
or let research at the time the
management had reasons for the decision
and the company handled it very well
actually nobody lost their jobs and
everybody was rewarded for the performed
work what I want to show you today is
what happened with my scientist
colleagues in me during the time in
between the announcement and the last
working day on our project considerate
of small case study on emotions and
science in 2015 our research team had
grown to more than 80 people and even
after the announcement that our project
was discontinued we could not stop
working from one day to another it took
several months to bring all activities
to a sound end and to find new jobs
within the company for everyone here's
what happens even though we knew that we
were working on a project that was to be
stopped during those months our output
hit the roof we were actually working on
two different all at projects firsts the
development of materials for blue
shining or LEDs which had started in
2001 and second materials for green or
LEDs which had started in 2014 and the
results I show you here concerned the
green OLED project in the graph you can
see how the lifetime which is a crucial
measure for the durability of our
devices developed over time in 2015
just half a year into the project we
were told to scale down to stop working
on the project as soon as possible and
to start over in other jobs nevertheless
from this time on our results continued
to improve rapidly how did that happen
after the announcement pretty quickly
colleagues started leaving the team and
soon we were left in a small crew all
pretty much sharing the same attitude of
I'm going to be the last person leaving
the ship what I mean is well the number
of scientists working on the project was
decreasing the dedication of people
remaining grew dramatically and also a
new and more intense team spirit formed
we all shared the same passion for our
work we always said that it was about to
end and we all wanted to show that we
could turn our ideas into reality we
felt that we belonged to something
bigger and furthermore our project was
less and less in the focus of the
management because they started to think
about new projects restructuring and so
on this resulted in additional freedom
and the possibility to take a few things
into our own hands of course more
freedom also means more responsibility
which we were happy to take because we
believed in our work we felt empowered
and these three pillars dedication
belonging and empowerment work together
in a kind of self reinforcing cycle and
the closer we got to shutdown the better
our output became so we were working
with such personal engagements on a
project already sentenced to death
because we felt connected to something
meaningful of course it was also a hard
and sometimes frustrating time but we
were sitting together in the lab or
occasionally in the cafe sharing our
sadness about the end of our project as
well as the Troy in our work
so overall we had a very intense and
mesmerizingly exciting time and the
lifetime we finally obtained for our
materials was on one level with already
commercialized materials for green
ohlet's at the time and we achieved this
within just one year and those results
helped our employer to sell the patents
for real value now let me tell you the
same story with different characters and
a slightly different operation the story
is part of Star Trek and sorry for those
of you who haven't seen the movies but I
need to introduce a spoiler here after
mr. Spock sacrificed himself to save the
Starship Enterprise at the end of Star
Trek to Captain Kirk and his core team
were determined to hunt through the
universe to search for Spock even though
they could see only very little chance
in finding him alive and stuff Lea
commands did not give them permission
nor a starship to do so so they took it
very passionately into their own hands
to travel out to find Spock and after
dealing with great challenges they
eventually found Spock and he happily
and gratefully joined the team again he
could feel the dedication and the
connection of his team towards their
project which was to save him and to
hold the crew together and over the
years over the episodes of the saga
mr. Spock came to realize that the
combination of both logic and emotions
is crucial for facing challenges and
exploring new worlds and there was no
contradiction anymore so the storyline
here for both our oled story and Star
Trek it's actually the basic setting for
a lot of freaks with stories in and out
of science the main characters are all
part of a great team all team members
show a huge dedication towards reaching
their goal they strive to seize all the
freedom they can get
and they take the responsibility they
need to take during the time our OLED
project was nearing the end I received
one piece of advice several times don't
take it to your heart you can work on
something else if I had followed it it
would have saved me several depressed
evenings and many tears but at the same
time I would have failed to gain a great
deal in personal development and
happiness and as the same is true for my
colleagues and our whole project we
would have achieved far less so of
course science should be based on facts
and logic when I say we should use our
emotions in science I do not suggest we
should use feelings instead effects but
I say we should not be afraid of using
our feelings to implement and to
catalyze fact-based science and
innovation emotions and logic do not
oppose each other they complement each
other and they reinforce each other the
feeling of being dedicated to something
meaningful of belonging to something
bigger and of being empowered is crucial
for creativity and innovation whatever
you are working on make sure that it
matters and take it to your heart as
much as you like
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]